after a three-year Hiatus Daniel TSH is
officially back not on your TV screen
but in your podcast feed with his brand
new Venture TSH show Welcome to Tosh.0
nope wrong show right welcome to Tosh
show ever since Tosh.0 was canceled by
Comedy Central back in 2020 fans of
Daniel TSH have often been left
wondering why hasn't he jumped in the
podcasting world and why do we never see
him as a guest on other comedy podcasts
well known for being somewhat Elusive
and rarely doing interviews Tasha's
always always kept a bit of mystery
around him which is why this move into
podcasting is a big exciting surprise
for the fans who've been missing his
unique brand of humor especially